four nations four democracies all with a
united message on the indo-pacific
region
what brings us together what unites us
is an affirmative vision for what the
future can bring
but but also a commitment to defend
uh the uh the rules-based system that we
have spent uh tremendous time and effort
building
that's the overriding focus of the quad
group of foreign ministers from the
united states india japan and australia
the security alliance says it supports
an open and inclusive vision and offers
an alternative to a china-led order in
the region and it's keen to push back on
china's expansion
our region is in a period of rising
strategic uncertainty the rules and
norms that have provided a foundation
for our stability and hence our
prosperity are under pressure
in particular from authoritarian regimes
of increasing concern to the quad is
beijing and moscow's announcement last
week of a strengthening relationship
with presidents xi jinping and vladimir
putin declaring a no-limits partnership
with mutual protection of each country's
core interests
as tensions between russia and nato
countries escalate over ukraine the u.s
secretary of state told the quad the
same principles in the indo-pacific
apply to russia
one of the reasons we're working so
intensely to defend the core principles
threatened by russia's aggression toward
ukraine is because those very same
principles are crucial to enduring
stability in this region
and every other part of the world
the u.s secretary of state flies to fiji
on saturday with this joint statement
he's aiming to reassure pacific leaders
that washington and its allies are
committed to providing security and
distributing covert 19 vaccines as well
as boosting investment in infrastructure
across the region and all of this while
china is ramping up its aid and
influence
beijing has labelled the quad alliance
as an inflammatory initiative designed
to undermine third parties like china
these foreign ministers have pledged
increased humanitarian relief terrorism
and cyber and marine security for
indo-pacific nations the quad's members
are expected to make further commitments
when they meet in japan in the middle of
the year sarah clark al jazeera brisbane
australia